- [Mark] All right, Jayme,
- Hmm.
- [Mark] Jayme. Oh, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Jayme] Originally I grew up in Quito.
It is a little town outside of Millington.
- [Mark] In Tennessee?
- [Jayme] Tennessee.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were young?
- Half and half.
Had a really rough childhood,
really really rough childhood.
But I excelled.
I was top of my class,
smartest for kindergarten on up
until I started dating a guy
that was way older than me.
Very abusive, and I was
scared to go to school.
So I went and got my GED
a little bit early when I was 16
and took some tests,
got to go do a little bit of college,
Nursing School.
Then got busted for prescription fraud,
but already had a full blown
addiction to pain pills
because of a car wreck.
And it just kind of escalated from there.
Pain pills, your body
builds up a tolerance.
Constantly, constantly, constantly.
And I'm at the point now where
I'm doing massive amounts of fentanyl.
And,
it started to not work.
So, I don't know what my next
plan of action is.
Other than having to quit.
- [Mark] After fentanyl,
there's not much left to do. Is there?
- Mm-mm. The Rohypnol that
Michael Jackson died off of,
but you're not gonna find
a doctor to monitor that.
- [Mark] And you're also smoking crack.
- I do. I smoke crack to balance out
the nod and the sleepiness.
I also do Xanax, have severe high anxiety.
I've had several attempts on my life.
I was stabbed in the back twice,
which resulted in two
open heart surgeries.
And I have a pacemaker.
Christmas time last year,
I uncovered a killer
that was killing girls
around the neighborhood
and he tried to kill me.
Kicked me until I had eight broken ribs.
My liver was split in three places.
My spleen was busted and
my stomach was busted.
I was dying.
They airlifted me to the med,
cut me from here to here
and left me open,
packed my insides for six days,
closed me up.
The minute I woke up from surgery,
they couldn't give me enough
pain medicine in the hospital.
So, I am AMA'd myself.
- [Mark] What is that?
- AMA Against medical advice.
I up and left directly after surgery.
- [Mark] Hm.
- That's insane.
- [Mark] So let's go
back to your childhood.
What was your childhood like?
Was there any abuse or anything like that?
- There was alcoholism in my family.
There was abuse, mental and physical.
A parent was removed from the home.
And when that happened,
the divorce happened
and the other parent went
a little bit, buck wild.
So, I had two brothers and
a sister that were younger.
I cared for them as much as possible.
My mom would come and give us money,
pay the bills, but pretty much it was
a free-for-all party house at my house.
We had a
acre big racetrack for
dirt bikes in my backyard.
And also a racetrack for BMX bikes.
Our house was the spot to hang out
for all the teenagers in Tipton County.
So, I started selling drugs.
Whatever I could get my hands on.
I did really well until,
like I said, I was busted
for prescription fraud and I
had actually got pretty far
in my nursing degree.
Screwed that all up.
I also have had charges
of counterfeit money,
making counterfeit money,
facilitating a counterfeit enterprise,
$187,000 worth of $100 bills. Counterfeit.
My husband signed
indictments affidavits on me.
I divorced him.
They had no major proof.
So, they had to drop it way, way down to
paraphernalia of counterfeit materials.
So, did a little bit more jail time.
So that's my, it's a little
bit of my background.
I learned early on there was sexual abuse,
not from my mom or my dad,
but from a man my mom chose to be with.
And there was massive abuse there.
- [Mark] How old were you?
- From what I can gather.
And from what people tell me,
I was probably four when
the grooming started.
And I remember I was 14 or I not quite 14.
It was like two weeks
before my 14th birthday
when the actual penetration happened.
And so it screws up your sexual mentality.
It really does.
It twists your mind into thinking
that that's all men want.
And then that's how
you get them, you know?
And it made me feel like
I wasn't worth anything.
And I was one of the top
softball players at my school.
Like I said, I had one
of the highest GPA's.
If I would've not got my GED
and finished until 12th grade
I probably would have gotten
a Historian of my class.
I was Student Council President from
sixth grade to 10th grade.
Regardless of anything that
went on in my home life.
I still excelled in those things.
I love working...
I'm an extremist, whatever I do, I do.
I'm the best at what I do.
No matter if it's selling
drugs, selling pussy,
selling whatever,
I try to be the best at it.
And I am most of the time, but...
- [Mark] So does this life
get you down sometimes?
You get depressed?
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] It must, right?
- Oh yeah.
- [Mark] I mean, it must
be difficult for a woman
to do this kind of work without being high
or drunk or something.
- Oh yeah.
Almost impossible.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Because,
men degrade you.
Not all of them.
But a lot of them.
I'm a fetish fantasy girl.
I do a lot of fetish fantasy work.
And, a lot of men have some
pretty serious fetishes.
Some of them want you to
act like their daughter,
have daddy daughter sex.
Some of them want to rape you.
They'll come in and act
like they're raping you.
And then at the end, they'll pay you.
But,
in a week's time, I'm probably
raped four times a week.
You become detached.
- [Mark] What's the hardest part of this.
What is the hardest part
of this life for you?
- The fear of
not seeing my kids again.
Of dying and not seeing my kids again.
- [Mark] Did that one trick
who tried to kill you?
Is that what kind of put his fear in you?
Or, I mean, the fear is
always there, isn't it?
- Do you know what a necrophiliac is?
- [Mark] Somebody who likes
having sex with dead people.
Yeah.
- For a long time, I had a necrophiliac,
hot on my trail.
(laughing)
He wanted to to have sex with me.
I dealt with that,
extremely terrifying.
From what I gather, he's
no longer in the picture.
It's a hard knock life.
How do you (laughs)
- [Mark] This must be far from the life
that you dreamed about as a kid, right?
- Far from it.
I wanted to be a lawyer or a veterinarian.
- [Mark] And now with
your addictions it seems
very unlikely that you'll get out, right?
- I could still be a lawyer.
I have enough school under
my belt that I could still,
- [Mark] Anything is possible.
- You know.
- [Mark] Fentanyl is
a tough drug to crack.
- It is.
- [Mark] Tough addiction.
- I had actually overcome it.
And relapsed.
So.
- [Mark] What do you think the
the core of all your
self-destructive behaviors is?
- Family.
No family support.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- The people that do make it
have family support.
I have a huge family,
but no support.
It's like, Oh my gosh!
They smoke weed and drink,
take little pills, but, Oh my gosh!
Heroin, Fentanyl, we
can't be a part of that.
So, you're disowned.
And I know you don't get
clean for your family,
but when you have the people
that you love surrounding you,
encouraging you, it
makes a big difference.
And also having a home to go back to.
I can't go back to my childhood home.
I'm not allowed.
So, I have to do what I have to do
to put a roof over my head.
- [Mark] Do you find the requests you get
from your customers gets a little extreme?
- Sometimes.
- [Mark] It's beyond what
you're comfortable doing?
- Sometimes, sometimes
they ask for bestiality.
Do you know what that is?
They want you to have sex
with one of their animals.
- [Mark] All right.
- Absolutely not somewhat to,
to get four, five people and
and beat you and rape you.
But they offer a thousand a piece,
but, that's out of the question.
There's a lot of somewhat,
you just shit in their mouth.
That's not something that I'm into.
People have fetishes
that I don't really see
how they they come about 'em.
I know how I came about my fetishes.
I have fetishes.
I like to be dominated.
I like to be tied up.
I'm one of those. (laughing)
I like toys.
I like minor amount of pain.
My sexual preferences or I don't
know what you would call it
my sexual orientation or whatever.
It isn't exactly healthy
as a doctor would put it or whatever,
but it works for me.
So, I also
don't know whether I
like men or women more.
My last relationship was with a woman,
a girl named Christie,
and she died three months ago.
- [Mark] Am sorry.
- That was hard.
The hardest part about all of this is,
watching everyone, you
know around you die,
'cause that's what happens.
Jails, institutions, or death.
That's the end of this road.
And even having the knowledge
of that, we still do it.
The fentanyl, the heroin,
I've been addicted to every drug
and was able to overcome it.
The fentanyl and the heroin.
It it's a whole, whole 'nother level.
It changes the chemical
makeup of your body.
It's absolute your biggest fear,
then becomes being sick off of,
not having those drugs.
That your biggest fear.
You would rather die.
- [Mark] I've heard that.
- Then, go through that sickness.
So, but, and then people get through it,
but your body never really recovers.
So, you think, well, I'm
just gonna try it again.
And one time, and you're hooked again.
it's a never ending cycle.
- [Mark] Who's raising your children?
- Well, my son is old enough to...
he moved up to Missouri
with his father finally,
and they're doing really good,
building a relationship.
My daughter has always lived with her dad.
My children have different dads.
And when me and my little
girl's father split up,
he took her and I took him.
And off and on.
He's had to go live with his granny
and my mom when I've had
to go to Jail and stuff.
But when he really left me
for a little while
because he wanted to go
to Dallas with his granny
and try something new, my
addiction really soared.
That's when it got really bad.
He came back.
I'd slowed down a lot,
but he was older.
He was bigger than me
and had a lot of anger.
He wanted to fight me a lot
and I couldn't fight him.
So, he's with his dad in Missouri now.
From what I hear, they're doing good.
He's almost 18.
He's working.
So, that makes me really happy.
Wherever my kids are,
as long as they're safe
and happy and protected,
that's what matters to me.
I'll sacrifice my feelings
in my heart so that they're
safe and well taken care of.
- [Mark] What's your biggest regret?
- My biggest regret was,
going to see doctor,
and getting on pain medicine.
Because before that, I
really didn't do drugs.
I didn't even smoke a cigarette.
And when I got on those
pain pills prescription
I thought prescription and they are okay.
He wrote me, he was a script writer.
He wrote me a,
Opana..
I don't know if you know what that is.
It's oxymorphone.
They give it to, to dying people.
Percocet, Lortab, Cenex,
Valium, Fentanyl. .
I get all that a month.
In one month.
And
that's my biggest regret.
I feel like if I never went to him that
I never would've
gotten a pill addiction.
And that's what started it.
'Cause once you're addicted to pills,
your body becomes dependent.
And so...
- [Mark] What's been the most
important lesson you've learned?
- This way of life, drugs,
all of this,
nobody's above it.
It can happen to anybody.
The best of us, the smartest of us.
It happens very quickly.
And that's,
I guess that's it that.
Nobody's immune to it. Nobody.
You get an addiction, your morals change.
And until rape is a normal
part of your life. (chuckling)
- [Mark] All right, Jayme.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- [Jayme] You're welcome.
- [Mark] I wish you the
best of luck with...
- [Jayme] Thank you.
- [Mark] Getting out of this street life.
- [Mark] And addiction.
- [Jayme] Thank you.